[Música]
[Aplausos]
vamos convidar a procurei comigo um
longo percurso que a fábrica de braga
fez do caos à inovação
a fábrica de braga vive os momentos de
grande crescimento ea fábrica de braga o
ano passado vendeu cerca de 516 milhões
e é muito curto prazo irá ultrapassar as
vendas e vai a única a ultrapassar os
mil milhões irá querer mais de três mil
trabalhadores da fábrica de braga hoje
deixou de ser uma fábrica transformou se
num pólo de inovação transformou se num
pólo desenvolvimento a fábrica de braga
hoje de facto tem os olhos colocados
nesta fábrica ea parceria da voz com a
universidade do minho facto ainda que
assumir um papel relevante
esta parceria só em projetos de inovação
o investimento totalizam 75 milhões de
euros
estamos a falar centenas de postos de
trabalho criados apenas para a inovação
mas está em um caminho e por isso é que
eu escolhi o tema do caos a inovação
como é que foi possível chegar aqui e
vamos fazer que o acompanhe neste neste
percurso pac três nomes boss e fm
european foundation for coloque - manhã
ea universidade do minho
nesse percurso que eu vou fazer e vou
cansar uns anos atrás do qual nascem as
estrelas neste projeto inovação do fac -
as estrelas
este é um projeto com muita dor com
muito sofrimento com muitos homens com
muitas mulheres envolvidas com várias
centenas como nos diz e temos que
regressar ao rival e 2010 em 2010 e
meados de 2010
eu convido meu diretor comercial senhor
week é mostrada a fábrica de braga ao
mundo braga estava muito fechado era
preciso que o braga se mostrar ao mundo
e concorrer aos prémios europeus da
influência
a reação deu foi de espanto como é
possível nós mostrarmos braga ao mundo
na dimensão do tocantins sim é possível
e eu em 15 minutos o matzá vamos embora
contigo acredita nós também acreditamos
e vamos embora porque o rival
bilbao todos nós nos lembramos global
país basco em tendentes à época turismo
mas mil val na europa e espetáculo vozes
da infância como foi possível em
conjunto com o turismo joão destro igual
transformar a mibal toda essa zona
ribeirinha de bilbao era uma zona
industrial cobra gravada bairros sociais
e esta gente acreditou que o fato era
possível seguir em frente e
transformaram radicalmente essa zona e
aqui podemos ver o centro de
conferências e once caldas que é onde
foi realizado o fórum europeu deste mês
em 2010
aqui ao lado temos a grande marca frank
ghery que o guaraná
o museu e do facto fórum ocorre nestas
duas nestas duas obras não euskal dona e
no governo tanto fórum historiador
alexandre tentou mostrar aos
participantes no fórum como é que o caos
à inovação ao órgão e como é que isto
fosse pra funcionar envolvendo o nome
chamado caótico leadership do fato o
desafiou a platéia a pensar fora da
caixa e ao momento qualquer um que o
caos se vai misturar animação da
criançada produzir valor e começa aqui
fato grande desafio pra mim também
tentar perceber como é que outras mentes
como é que outras mentes se posicionavam
e gostou uma emoção esta senhora uma
grande amiga rita
como disse eu convido a minha missão é
cantar só estamos europeus desconhecia e
maio é realizada a primeira avaliação
internacional após praga é liderada por
as holandesas iii eta uma ilustre amiga
em que a auditoria começa na
segunda-feira na quarta 3 mil
entrevistas ea quinta feira normalmente
reservada para o jogador não havia um
consenso e esta senhora conceição sempre
polêmicas são sempre quente no final ia
liga não quer falar comigo pessoalmente
eu ao estoque mas ela está com ele vai
na reunião do conselho para que falar
comigo pessoalmente algo não está a
correr bem e ela tentou perceber uma
conversa privada comigo tendo a certeza
que o limite dado ao nosso lado se não
fosse uma empresa
temos aqui muitas parcerias dentro da
mostra mas de facto não conseguiu
identificar o valor está correto
estou a ver vai de vosso problema e você
está a ver claramente nosso problema
ea pergunta ela precisa de ajuda e eu
disse eu preciso do jogo mas não sou eu
e meu país precisa de ajuda também é
preciso de facto irá aproveitar as
universidades e aqui começando a ter
esta grande história de inovação e ela
vem já vou te ajudar e traz fazer o
curso
então ela no relatório feedbacks o fato
estica o texto a favor das parcerias a
favor do conhecimento do acordo a
ciência começa aqui fato o grande
desafio é bosch em outubro desloca-se a
munique
a fábrica é o mar foi desta que lutava
obra de engenharia munique e novembro
ambos países europeus de ações foram
entregues
é aqui que gosta é o primeiro prémio da
poesia e equipe pelo fato acontece uma
coisa pra mim é inacreditável e cartoons
conhecem este ano deu a volta ao mundo
com seu projeto solar impulse toda a
gente fala mas nessa altura quando este
senhor branco fórum mostra ocupa sol
para perseguir seu sonho que era voar
sem uma gota de combustível para mim
quando eu me mostra a testar a fusão
agem tratada numa carrinha na estrava um
pouco dinheiro é fazer o teste
acreditava no seu sonho depois quando eu
faço primeiro teste um vôo noturno sem
combustível está em terra com medo que o
avião que isso tudo em silêncio à espera
que algo acontecesse o primeiro teste na
manhã seguinte quando o avião aterra na
pista ver se está tudo a correr atrás do
avião a gritar carro seguia atrás do
avião pouco várias tomem acreditou que
era possível dar a volta ao mundo e deu
a volta ao mundo sair monique gota de
combustível por isso pra melhor pra mim
facto foi um momento de perceber que é
preciso acreditar é preciso sonhar não
sonhou o quer voar sem combustível foi
possível
braga fazer agora o primeiro desafio
convencer a minha administração
nós iremos caminhar num sentido
diferente e se eu estaria disponível
para aceitar uma parceria que fosse
estruturado que fosse capaz de partir a
louça pensar fora da caixa
e eu disse sim eu estou contigo eu
pronta e três vezes e vou fazer o mesmo
com três meses vamos viver momentos
ruins eu quero saber se eu falar comigo
caso contrário não vale a pena que não
tenho compromisso em cima eu não vou
partir a louça e ela vai eu vou
continuar segundo desafio convencer a
universidade do minho estará ela
disponível ou não entrar numa aventura
complexa estará ou não o reitor
disponível para esta luta e eu peço uma
reunião com o reitor a reunião acontece
nos três dias depois
imediatamente o que eu digo é eu não
venho aqui propor nenhuma parceria
simples - propor ao complexo algo
estruturante o descaso não for assim não
estou interessado neste parcerias
escolheu outras pessoas e eu eu vou à
luta com quem vamos embora vídeo manda
uma outra coisa as pessoas colocarem a
trabalhar comigo que tenham um poder de
abstração elevado que tem uma visão
macro não venham para cá com coisas
muito a cada gestão temos aqui um
problema quatro dias depois eu coleciono
joão monteiro antônio pontos
guardo gostam pelo advogado como saiba
que grande aventura outubro 2011 a
construção de uma grande história de
inovação como diz que volta de 5 milhões
de euros de investimento
epa chegados a novembro de 2011 um ano
depois eu não me interessava processo de
inovação criação - 15 milhões a 25
milhões delas eu criei muita gente eu
queria que tivesse um efeito
multiplicador na economia não cria
projetos pequenos
chegados a novembro de 2012
gosta não queria funcionava alguma
funciona mas esta não queria funcionar e
eu nem o meu colega pedro delgado um dia
chuvoso quinta feira cinzenta pronunciar
qualquer coisa de errado e nem com o meu
colega pedro delgado pedro nós temos que
encontrar aqui daí as altamente
financiáveis inovadoras e 17 milhões nós
não conseguimos fazer nada de estrutural
no sistema gerando pedro pedro desabafou
em cima de mim tá procuramos um ano
imensa as reuniões nós chegamos aqui
para a empresa não quer pensar fora da
caixa e nós vamos paramos aqui e eu
existo outros inteiro não vamos desistir
estamos aqui vamos ter que lutar vamos
ter que continuar a caminhar e eu queria
baixar os braços não podemos baixar do
8º acontece para os deuses alinharam se
ouvia nas consolas brilhante na sexta
feira para que é que se passa o pedro 66
no mundial ele ainda tem uma solução
para pode passar aqui
o pedro naquela noite não via ter
dormido eu tenho a vida e as financiava
os eu tenho as pessoas calculadas e eu
tinha praticamente descobriram a solução
para pôr o projecto acima de 15 milhões
quer aqui um facto cria e dali até maio
de 2003 quando só temos a candidatura
muitas coisas aconteceram e eleições o
projeto vai provar outra vez mais de 15
milhões mas as equipas já estavam no
terreno já sabiam como gerir o caos e
puseram um fato o investimento
assim nós que se daqui primeiro pois é
fato que totalizou us 9 milhões mas isto
gerir o facto o mundo académico com o
mundo empresarial não é fácil são a de
ienes de frente
qual é o ponto fusão destas duas
entidades é complexo há muitas - há
muitos e usar muitos nós do fato júri
projetos de inovação é facto de
percebermos como é que podemos gerir o
caos como é que podemos magoar o caos e
isto são centenas de pessoas envolvidas
a imensa as equipas
todos temos um objetivo comum é realizar
o projeto é transformar braga num centro
de ensino centro de inovação e é isso
que o fato
nós conseguimos fazer o nosso avião
conseguiu levantar em 2003 como picar o
projeto termina no dia 30 de junho de
2015 e os novos projectos life to
innovate o cara tinha mais erram
precisamente oficialmente no dia 5 às
máquinas de construção de candidaturas
foram talvez prefeitas que uma casa num
dia e o outro começa no dia seguinte por
isso o primeiro totalizou 9 milhões e
chegou e segundo totalizam 55 milhões
por isso acreditamos sonhamos e
conseguimos o facto por o avião voar
objetivo que nós fizemos desde o início
é que o facto tivéssemos centenas de
pessoas envolvidas em projetos de
inovação é que nós somos capazes de
contaminar todo o ambiente externo a voz
em que estas pessoas vão andar por aí
com um processo de divórcio não vamos
pegar e começam a ser contratado as
próprias empresas
sonho que nós tínhamos era que o fato
houver projetos de inovação mas ao ver
essas centenas os envolvidos que
provassem do veneno da inovação se
quiserem mas foi incapaz de se unirem
num objetivo comum que é a inovação
o facto é um caso de sucesso notável e
como podem ver os números são
gigantescos cerca de 800 900 pessoas
envolvidas 400 pessoas contratadas
altamente qualificadas do fato braga
neste momento é capaz estamos
trabalhando com isso está realmente é um
outro caminho é preciso ser disruptivo é
preciso acreditar e este não gostou holz
braga nunca tempo tente o escolar em
patentes em braga calvário propriedade
intelectual ela destrua industrial é
qualquer coisa vulgar quisermos mas como
nós adoramos o caos e conseguimos mudar
o causa está o novo grande desafio para
o país
são 55 milhões mas a boston uma decisão
e roche importa ou melhor compra em
portugal apenas 10% dos seus componentes
estão desastre econômico nacional e para
as importações e as exportações
então eu goste se é sociedade como
comprar meus produtos ea sociedade como
recursos humanos qualificados e eu
também tenho que dar qualquer coisa a
cidade então tomamos uma decisão
estratégica que é convidar mais
fornecedora francesa após o encontro ao
invés de comprarmos -10% comprarmos
entre 15 e 25 por cento e isto vai
obrigar a posicionar nossa indústria
nacional e por isso neste projeto a
capacitação de formadores nacionais
conectar domínio é que estou mais
parceiros associados
por isso este é um projeto complexo
estão envolvidos cerca de 40
fornecedores só que volvidos o colostro
tecnologias e colocando componentes e
aqui podemos ver a realidade neste
projecto o investimento variável rondará
os 100 milhões de euros e mais uma vez
aqui temos empresas micro e médias e
grandes empresas o que o projeto
consiste a voz conhece o roadmap futuro
das tecnologias e partilha com os
fornecedores quem é que vocês querem
abraçar este desafio
os futuros do s ou não aquilo que querem
capacitar e
bosko universidade do minicom outras
entidades tema científico nacional irá
capacitar mas foram soltos mas este foi
um estouro na realidade vão ter que
desenvolver também processos ágeis
dentro da sua organização porque podem
ser capacitadas científicamente mas é o
preço é com o elevado dos seus produtos
que irá editar ou não ganhar concurso e
criar uma casa e eu vou entrar em um
universo de bosh para ser uma fronteira
gosta gosta em todo o mundo eo país
beneficiará com isto
por isso a voz também irá ajudar os
fornecedores a capacitá los a um nível
que o processo está nos tornando mais
ágeis mais flexíveis mas somente numa
ideia deste projecto irá nascer a
academia gosta de mim e também um grande
desafio que deve lá nós começamos a
perceber que as universidades não estão
a produzir o conhecimento do quadro para
as empresas e por isso esta academia e
vai ser financiada dentro deste projeto
capacitação dos fundos nacionais quando
tem dois grandes objetivos é qualificar
os ativos da bosch conhecimento
inscritos ficando hoje não existem nos
nossos colaboradores e também permitirá
que os todos os nossos fornecedores para
um par desta por fornecedores ao
conhecimento fornecido por esta academia
por isso este é um grande desafio para a
fábrica de braga é do facto permitir que
se compra em portugal feminino às
importações somente as exportações como
os dias este avião espera se que durante
o vôo no primeiro trimestre
a parte científica do projeto está
fechada os fornecedores também estão
fechados
agora estão a decorrer reuniões com o
governo para enquadrar customizar uma
solução que seja a capacidade
competitiva que nos nacionais e
contaminou outras grandes multinacionais
por exemplo março enquanto ela fazer o
mesmo transferir fornecimentos externos
para financiamentos internos e ajudar a
nossa economia a tornar-se mais tentaram
por isso atrás do carro nas linhas
estrelas há tempos turbulentos na
sucesso e nós em braga facto só vai
mexer diferentes só vamos acreditar foi
foram discussões
o governo porque criam que a solução
fosse de uma forma e nós não queremos e
por aí
nós queremos seguir em frente nós
queremos abrir guanacos conceitos e
conseguimos porque na realidade em
conjunto com neste domínio
nós soubemos ser diferente como diz a
centenas pessoas envolvidas nisto
projetos de grande sucesso só fazem com
homens e mulheres que acreditam e para
todos os réus muito obrigado e termino
aqui minha apresentação
[Aplausos]
[Música]